[Música]
y nuestra segunda invitada al día es
completamente de lujo estamos hablando
de laura restrepo periodista y escritora
colombiana laura para nosotros es un
gusto un placer que estés con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24
bienvenida al encantador redoble muchas
gracias por esta invitación laura una
mujer de delirio eso es lo que
despiertas en los lectores no
quisiera empezar hablando antes de
presentar este este más reciente el
libro que escribió esta novela canción
de antiguos amantes de del proceso
creativo cuál es el proceso creativo de
laura restrepo para para realizar una de
las tantas obras maestras que ha escrito
bastante bien no de la fascinación con
todo lo que pasa con todos sus sus
milagros y con todos sus terrores
también yo creo que vivimos épocas muy
difíciles
de hecho épocas como muy cercanas al
final de la especialmente queremos un
timonazo bárbaro y entonces
la literatura sale de la fascinación de
hablar con la gente de ver cómo se las
arregla la gente para sobrevivir la
alegría que hay de todas maneras a pesar
de las dificultades es la dignidad de la
gente es como una fuente de inspiración
tú sabes que como colombianos pues aquí
nunca nos ha tocado fácil es una vida de
nación que ha sido muy despiadada y como
colombianos somos pelea piel leones y
peleadores y salimos adelante y es como
esta energía lo que siempre me ha
llevado a mí escribir que le fascina al
aura todo que la desvela esto todo soy
muy acelerada y no puedo tomar café
aunque soy color blanco porque quedó
colgada en la lámpara así se acelere te
colombiano entonces todo me encanta soy
muy viajera
y me encantan los sitios donde no
conozco el idioma donde al fin de
cuentas uno reconoce como a sus hermanos
ya sus hermanas cierto esa sensación de
que estás en casa en todos lados de que
los problemas son los mismos de que la
vocación de vida viene siendo la misma
entonces no hay todos mis libros son muy
distintos entre sí porque yo pienso
bueno necesito como el impulso de la
novedad de meterme con un tema nuevo
porque yo pienso que si yo me aburro
escribiendo como lectores la guerra y el
conflicto de alguna manera siempre han
estado en su vida digamos que usted fue
negociadora de pase con el gobierno del
presidente belisario betancur con la
guerrilla del m-19 como fue todo este
proceso
fue duro fue un proceso duro pero pero
enormemente vital mira que ahora con
este conflicto con con ucrania tan
aterrador y si uno como es posible que
las potencias no se sientan a negociar
por favor si es que están a punto de
estamos a punto de una guerra nuclear
porque no se sientan a negociar
entonces pues en el extranjero y no
viniendo de colombia la gente tiene la
sensación de que uno viene de un país
muy violento y es verdad voy ser de
colombia sabemos negociar en colombia
hemos tenido enfrentamientos brutales
pero con todas las dificultades nosotros
nos sentamos a negociar es lo primero
que al colombiano se le pasa por la
cabeza busquemos la paz como sea
entonces yo creo que de todas maneras
esos procesos a nosotros nos han marcado
como un pueblo que entiende que la paz
es fundamental para sobrevivir y que los
nacionalismos y el heroísmo ese
patriotero eso no ya no sirve no lleva a
ningún lado el aura si hablaba de
conflictos porque de eso también más o
menos se trata digamos
a esta nueva novela canción de antiguos
amantes aquí está la última novela que
usted escribió y pues quiero leer un
pedazo de lo que más o menos la escribe
una obra de ficción basada en los viajes
que la autora usa usted la verdad es
trepó hizo con médicos sin fronteras por
yemen etiopía y la frontera somalí pues
obviamente unos países llenos de
conflictos internos cómo se desarrolla
en esta esta obra de ficción pero además
basada en su propia vivencia usted
primero también digamos que pensé que
bien para hablarle a interrumpir cómo
hacer ese ese proceso de investigación
para que luego venga venga la creación
mira yo he ido a muchas partes con
médicos sin fronteras cuando me invitan
yo voy ojalá como médica me ha encantado
ser médica pero no es el caso pero me
invitan digamos a sitios donde de
conflictos crónicos que ya los medios
han olvidado mucho entonces llevan un
escritor para que le dé y un estupendo
fotógrafo para como revivir el del
interés por el tema que los medios lo
vuelvan a publicar entonces con ellos en
la india en méxico en colombia en los
campos de sirios en grecia siempre que
habitan hay misma well maletín y y me
voy con ellos porque eso se mete en esos
lugares del mundo donde ya nadie llega a
ser donde el conflicto es tan crítico
que ya nadie llega y además se meten con
el espíritu de curar que también es muy
bueno es cierto no solamente la tragedia
humanitaria sino la posibilidad aunque
sea chiquitica de estar allí de estar
presente de acompañar
y pues nosotros los colombianos en
conflictos nadamos como pez en el agua
pues eso no nos amedrenta ahí vamos y
entonces hice ese viaje por por yemen
bueno fueron tres viajes por esa zona
que tú mencionas yo no sabía nada la
verdad por ahí nunca había estado sabía
que era el antiguo territorio de lo que
había sido el mítico reino de saba eso
sabía y siempre he leído mucho a un
autor francés que es andré malraux y
había leído su libro sobre el contrato
una avioneta y sobrevoló el yemen
buscando las ruinas del antiguo reino de
saba ya es ahora como la referencia que
yo tenía pero lo que me llamó muchísimo
la atención raúl es que es el río de
mujeres migrantes que vienen subiendo
por el cuerno de áfrica y se meten
desierto adentro nos puede atravesar en
pateras en el golfo de adén
ríos de mujeres con sus hijas buscando
un lugar donde la vida sea posible
y
con la piel quemada por el sol y por la
sal y la ropa en harapos descalzas
muchas veces pero cuando te acercas a
preguntarle si tú quién eres de dónde
viene salió un orgullo dentro y me decía
nosotros somos descendientes de la reina
de saba yo soy la es así como saber tú
tendrás todo tú quién eres yo yo soy la
descendiente de las reinas a él me
encantó ver como buen o mal robo se
equivocó al buscar desde el avioneta
porque la reina de saba está ver ahí
abajo en cada una de estas mujeres
migrantes entonces pensé para bueno sí
siempre publique entre cada uno de esos
viajes de publicada el reportaje es
cierto en españa y por américa latina y
así pero con la idea de hacer os dejo
una novela y está formando eso en
ficción
entonces de ahí salió es una doble
historia de amor por un lado la mítica
historia de amor de salomón y la reina
esa reinventada por mi como me dio la
gana
creo que los mitos se mantienen vivos en
la medida en que los reinventa y al
mismo tiempo el protagonista que son
muchachos digamos contemporáneo
enamorado de la reina de saba que sale a
buscarla por el mundo ya se encuentra
con una partera somalí que de alguna
mujer así potente que ayuda al dar a las
mujeres de la luz en medio de la guerra
por los caminos una mujer poderosa que
de alguna manera también en ella se
encuentra
la reencarnación si se quiere cómo se
revive el antiguo método de esta mujer
sabia y poderosa que fue la la reina de
saba en la leyenda la ahora también hay
un hilo conductor en casi todas sus
novelas quiero leer una frase de nada
menor y garcía márquez su fascinación
por la cultura popular y su humor
impecable ahorran a sus novelas
cualquier tentación hacia el patetismo o
melodrama e infunden placeres de lectura
inconfundibles cómo lograr este humor
también acertado ciclo y raúl que es muy
colombiano también los colombianos
hacemos unos chistes tremendos sobre las
cosas más duras sí a veces los
extranjeros se quedan fríos pero yo creo
que el humor es una forma de defensa es
una forma de enfrentar la contrariedad y
decir yo puedo con ella yo no tengo por
dónde agarrarla cierto como
vencer el miedo también yo creo que con
el humor se vence el miedo y es una cosa
muy de del pueblo colombiano y yo
pretendo que mis novelas no quiere decir
para nada ahorrar digamos la tragedia
humanitaria que hay detrás de un libro
como éste pero si también mostrar cómo
la gente tienen la fortaleza de
enfrentar cierto en medio de todo el
destierro del desplazamiento esas
multitudes por el camino es una gran
aventura es el valor que tiene el que
con una mano adelante y otra atrás
agarra su madrecita vieja y a sus hijos
y sus corotos y hecha por el mundo a
vivir la gran aventura de fundación al
cierto de llevar una cultura de un sitio
a otro evadir la guerra burlar el hambre
el frío la sed para mí eso es una gran
aventura además es el mismo río de gente
que sale de las desplazadas colombianas
va pasando por el áfrica atraviesa en el
mediterráneo se van por estas tierras
del cuerno de áfrica el sur de la
península arábiga y finalmente uno
siente que es el mismo río de gente el
que va buscando lugares donde la vida
sea posible la obra agradece también en
este libro a tu abuelo enrique restrepo
escritor dice quien asoma a estas
páginas como mirsa husayn la importancia
de su abuelo pues imagínate lo curioso
mi abuelo fue escritor enrique restrepo
aquí en bogotá y nosotros seremos mi
hermana y ahora damos su biblioteca pero
también había un baúl que yo me había
llevado para barcelona donde estoy
viviendo donde había manuscritos de
novelas inéditas y yo no lo había
abierto cuando estaba en medio de la
escritura este libro me dio por escarbar
en el baúl me encuentro con el que el
abuelo tenía un manuscrito de una novela
sobre yemen
titularísimo primero yo escribiendo de
yemen que tenía que ver y de pronto el
abuelo también un libro sobre la mente y
entonces ese como vértigo que siente
desde pronto esto es como una tarea
heredada que mi abuelo no terminó y yo
tengo que terminarla
el libro de él era muy encantador estaba
narrado por un personaje que se llama
mis ojos y entonces yo dije pues a la
olla al abuelo aquí lo voy a meter de
personaje de la novela y tengo en ese
personaje frases que son del texto del
abuelo así que fue como muy emocionante
pensar que de alguna manera no podía
continuar con un propósito que le había
tenido la obra usted se define como una
rebelde
si ya me llevan a mi la rebeldía hay que
vivir en rebeldía es hospitalidad no
tragar entero no me gustan las
instituciones no me gusta el poder yo
creo que el escritor tiene que estar en
las antípodas del poder siempre y que es
indispensable con esa visión crítica
permanente cuestionamiento
también con alegría y con comprensión y
con humor pero pero si para mí la
rebeldía la rebeldía es la fuente de
todo dolor marte en todos los niveles
cierto y las crisis que vivimos digamos
no sea este conflicto se me viene a la
cabeza actualmente en ucrania y rusia
qué tal que tan vital a pesar de la
tristeza obviamente y la crueldad de
estos conflictos son para el
enriquecimiento de la cultura y el día
el renacimiento de alguna manera raúl yo
estoy convencida que entre esta guerra
que se está cocinando que bien puede ser
donde las potencias no negocian bien
puede ser una guerra atómica es decir no
hay tercera guerra que no sea atómica es
la pongamos en la firma la crisis
ecológica el planeta no aguanta más la
crisis económica se viene tan brutal las
desigualdades el hambre la pobreza yo
creo que estamos en el momento en que la
humanidad se replantea para que ésta
aquí sobre el planeta y da un gran
timonazo o de verdad estamos en el borde
de al borde de la extinción entonces es
un llamado a cualquiera que tenga una
actividad de información de creación de
pensar de hacer de ver cómo hacemos cómo
agarramos los pedazos y volvemos a
reconstruir algo para que nuestros hijos
y nuestros nietos tengan una casa donde
vivir mejor dicho tengan un planeta
donde vivir yo creo que si bien es una
situación muy dura al mismo tiempo
también es una invitación muy fuerte a
replantearnos todo la ética la estética
la política las normas de convivencia
recuperar la solidaridad recuperar la
fascinación por el prójimo
entonces si yo creo que por ejemplo para
también para todos los informadores y
comunicadores es una oportunidad muy
interesante de mirar más allá de las
convenciones cierto las convenciones en
los cayeron totalmente amos al filo del
desastre o no sabíamos o como el chiste
estamos al borde del abismo y dimos un
paso adelante